I've been trying to contribute something
about variety that I had hoped and I
haven't succeeded that I hoped would
change the very nature of the way
theatre is produced and who comes to the
theater because you know the theater is
a very segregated place most of the
people who run theaters are in this
country are white people my generation
had many promising directors and
producers and writers and they're not
around they're not making theatre and it
breaks my heart and I feel in some ways
that I haven't contributed nearly enough
in terms of what my thought about that
was when I first was studying acting in
a theater where everybody on the stage
was white and everybody in the audience
was white and I thought it's so weird
i'm in san francisco there's asian
people up the hill there's black people
across the bay there's every kind of
person here there's latinos all over the
mission how could this theater of this
town have everybody white on the stage
unless was a black guy bringing in a
pizza a character bringing the pizza and
everybody in the audience is what how
did that be so i thought well well maybe
if I figure out a way to bring more
colors of people onto the stage more
colors of people will come to the
audience that hasn't happened so you
know I think there's so much work yet to
be done in the American theater so that
it as a cultural form can help mirror
the Magnificent way that this country
has changed since the time I was a girl
in Baltimore but I just don't feel it
has and it breaks my heart it breaks my
heart